what's up reject nation i got ashley
ender back with me today
ashley follow her on social media
please do she bought so many followers
and now she wants
real followers
and with her here we have to do it try
not to laugh
yeah i feel like we do this every time
like we have to make this a thing now
that every time we have to do it
every time and and the thing is you
always lose i know it's so
upsetting i'm not going to
with the family guy the one with you
might be the most viewed one you're a
commodity here on the channel
you're an asset we must maintain
friendship at all costs
do you think that one day which i don't
even know if they make these but do you
think one day we can do a friend's
try not to laugh uh i'm sure that exists
would that be
easy since we probably know all the
jokes and everything
that would be that would be so simple i
feel like i feel like that should be the
next challenge next time i'm here
all right fine just for you we'll do it
but until then
family guy family guy oh this one's
gonna be family guy roasting
every celebrity
what is that it's my magic 8-ball this
is the first black ball
that kim kardashian hasn't played with
we now return to jeremy piven
as the incredible hulk you wouldn't like
me when i'm angry
i don't like you now fine [ __ ] i'll read
1984.
you better cause this was more
embarrassing than when we played truth
or dare with present-day madonna
um truth do i look younger than 90.
yeah this is pitbull's house he knows
everything about south florida
he can help us find mort doorbell
doorbell
doorbell ring it's my house
wow imagine kind of knowing two
languages
you lost for the first time this morning
you know i don't like a big face big fat
face
okay and what about for your body yeah
you know veins all kinds of veins
everywhere
everywhere oh i guess you learn
something new every day
like the black eyed peas hey what's that
this is a guitar wow because you're
beautiful meg thanks to you come on let
me introduce you to the president
he's kind of like my boyfriend
oh hang on he's still getting ready
why are you so fat okay ask him about
anything but his weight
uh uh you act asian you look native
american
your name is possibly jewish what are
you
a fat i don't have a housekeeper and i
think you're just present-day arnold
schwarzenegger no
i'm a machine every second i'm not
having sex with a housekeeper
robots are killing people in the future
okay
i finished my day you lied to me you do
have a housekeeper
let's go make a large-faced boy god i'm
not going to die
what do you mean of course you are i'm
not going to die brian i'm like jim
belushi
i am worried about my funny brother
though
[Music]
this is tragic but we'll also open the
door for me
we now return to extreme makeover
bethany frankel edition
that was my pleasure too peter yeah i
knew i'd get you just like danny devito
got ria perlman
i don't know danny look it's either me
or nobody
really are you sure oh yeah this is
nothing i've been in uncomfortable
situations before
like whenever i meet famous people hey
what's up
i'm snoop dogg you know what i'm saying
i do
but you don't beat it you don't look at
that
who's hiding out down here he's a jewish
pharmacist from rhode island
goropo motel tells you and here's
pitbull with his newest hit
tinta tanka titan tanty
[Music]
adios goodbye amigo friends i gotta go
get paid to scream make some noise
in vegas oh yeah peanut butter cup
doritos sausage company
and let's crack a cadbury egg over the
whole thing
i can use my spare glove compartment
underwear as a napkin
i can't believe randy quaid gets to eat
like this every day
it's brian that's more ridiculous than
the theory of why tom cruise runs in all
his movies
wow that camera man has nice strong arms
you can't catch me gay thoughts
you're a worse parent than britney
spears
god that must be where they do the deed
i hope it's at least peaceful and humane
oh boy magic 8-ball is the fox network
sustainable in this new streaming world
no no
ken what's wrong a black ball went to
waste
lois where the devil is everyone this
place is more deserted than james
gandolfini's workout room
[Laughter]
the spiderweb
excuse me which one was lindsay lohan's
dessert fork i think it was that one
in fact i see stewie reading a book
scratch and sniff
lindsay lohan goes jogging
oh god that's terrible oh here's a
pop-up book
tommy lee goes boating
elderly potheads why did it have to be
elderly potheads chris that's not tyrese
what are you talking about they look
nothing alike ludacris looks like a
human peanut and tyrese looks slick
he looks like a chinese black like
africa and asia had sex while europe sat
on a chair in the corner of the hotel
room and watched
ludicrous human peanut tyrese chinese
black it's gonna be crazier than
whatever kanye west is doing at this
particular moment
i'm giving this lasagna
stop joining isis thank you for your
interest don't forget
like this
we now return to joni loves chris brown
joanie chris welcome to the party can i
offer you some punch
no thanks joey loves chris brown was
taped in front of a very uncomfortable
studio
hey chris brown i just wanted to say i'm
a huge fan of your music
this is just going to make me listen
more oh hey ray rice
would you want to press in the lobby
what do you got potatoes in your ears i
said press lobby
i know i'm having to get more fun and
when i i mean
then when we went fiona apple picking
like they're all gruesome filthy yeah
these
oh my god made some bad choices with
women
but there's another way haagen-dazs lots
of haagen-dazs
let's see if it worked here we go ha
you're still alive you
fat i haven't seen this much denial
since john travolta married kelly
preston
john do you take kelly to be your wife i
totally do i mean yeah yes
absolutely and i'm gonna do stuff to it
too like
touch her yeah touch her and
kiss her and touch your penis
don't worry lois peter's good at getting
out of trouble just like kobe bryant we
want the truth kobe
did you rape her
what were we talking about hey some of
our greatest actors started the news
like sean pan today's weather calls for
uh
breezy skies and sun and it's
forget about yourself for a second
counter look what has happened to
jonathan lipnicki
oh yeah no you're you're right you
should probably take care of that
that's the coolest george clooney there
is hi george clooney second worst batman
speedy griffin second best homer
you may have heard jokes on the set
one time i nailed nora dunn in the head
with an apple
that's hilarious because you're handsome
otherwise you're just some dick who hit
a lady
and you you're done clean up your locker
kicked out i'm totally screwed like
those poor guys who had to come up with
a new ad campaign for subway
hey i'm mike i like sandwiches and
people my own age
subway please don't think of pedophilia
oh wow
well i think that it's pretty clear who
lost this
you're the only one that i know who's
taken
so seriously
oh
i feel really accomplished you can take
out the headphones oh
well it's okay all right they're kind of
comfortable all right
keep them on all you want i'll join you
why not because i have to put a back on
i found this one particularly hard to
not laugh
yeah and it kind of dawned on me close
to wrapping this
up and i think it has something to do
with the fact of like yes i'm constantly
being updated on celebrities lives
all the time with social media stuff but
i also you know just kind of love
watching celebrity interviews and
hearing about their craziness and all
that
i am part of the culture that is
obsessed with celebrities yes
i am problematic condone me all you want
but you're watching this video too
so yeah yeah whatever we're all a part
of it because it gets into like the
gossip stuff too like even like the
thing with arnold like that's what made
me really laugh
i thought that was super funny but i
just love their joke about kanye i love
the self-awareness of like the second
homer simpson bit was so funny
the god again i knew it was gonna be
trump and they're doing something and i
just didn't know what it was gonna be so
i thought that was pretty funny
the pit bull one that's important to be
able to speak two like
kind of thing two languages i mean some
of them are so
so harsh though you know that's why some
of them are like you wanna laugh but
it's also like oh like the heath ledger
one to me that
always feels like it's too soon even
though that was so long ago like it
still feels houston but they've done a
few things for lindsay lohan it seems
yeah they really like to take jabs at
kim kardashian
it's weird how like i just finished i
watched the sopranos with olivia james
gandolfini passed away
it's funny because i share that
sentiment with you about heath ledger
for some reason i'm always like
yeah it's like you feel a little like a
little bad about
it but for some reason with james
gandolfini i'm like that was hilarious
yeah there were some there were some
good ones in there for sure but i think
maybe the james gone i'll feed one
wasn't about his death but more about
not
willing to work out yeah i did like the
way that they made like the
gem look so spooky
it was some pretty funny stuff there was
a lot of good ones in there i liked it
man when it comes to roasting i feel
like family guy is the absolute best at
it i also love when a snoop dogg was
talking and peter's like i don't know
i don't know what you're talking about
peter just whenever he has
that like inner dialogue to himself i
love that so much
yeah this is one of the funniest ones
i've seen
this is undoubtedly this is one of the
funniest ones i've seen clearly because
you lost
okay all right let's get you out of here
we'll follow ashley on instagram is that
the only one you have
i just have one instagram yes i mean do
you tweet
uh i don't tweet no i don't we need to
get you and i don't really
either i did see the social dilemma
that's a whole nother video
just in so follow her on instagram with
that in mind
uh subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification
bell hit the like button blah blah blah
last but not least let's do a
david gandy david i saw that recently
you moved to arizona you made the big
leap
after a tiresome year after a lot of
hurdles and troubles you've had to deal
with
you finally made the move and you're
starting fresh
all over again in the great state of
arizona
i just want to wish you the best sorry
for the time that you were in california
we never
made that trip to go up and see you in
northern california but you know what
that doesn't matter right now what
matters is
i believe you're going to be leading a
much happier life from here on out
i'm proud of you for making this move it
seems like what's best for you
and i wish you the best of luck while
you're out there
and regardless we're always going to
stay in touch my friend
hell yeah maybe we'll come visit you in
arizona maybe maybe you're closer now
than you were before i don't think
that's how it works that's how i choose
to but
let's see what happens
you